vsauce kevin here and i'm being mugged
by a baby wallet please no no i'm not
giving you my wallet stop your
abbreviating and give me your wallet
this is a mugging no it's not a mugging
i'm trying to make a math video and you
are a
baby
child
doll thing you're not mugging me oh yes
i am how much scratch is in the wallet
of yours jack my name is kevin not jack
and not a lot of money like 10 bucks now
go away here's the deal if i take your
wallet today i'll find you tomorrow and
give you 20
that's a 100 return on being bugged by
me what
come on there's there's no way that
you'll possibly make good on that deal i
i can't trust you you you're just some
creepy
thieving baby doll i heard both your
game huh ten times then
ten times i'll give you one hundred
dollars tomorrow for stealing ten bucks
today huh
this is kind of like a decent deal no
no no no this is ridiculous where are
you gonna get a hundred dollars tomorrow
ah no i'm not giving you my wallet i'm
keeping like ten bucks ten thousand
dollars what ten thousand dollars
tomorrow for ten bucks right now buddy
boy actually
this is starting to get interesting give
me a second to think about this go over
here i need to start considering the
odds of this actually happening what are
the odds of a child jumping me on the
street and then making good on their
promise to give me more money tomorrow
this is the only way i can decide i can
compare the probability of it happening
relative to the payoff i'll get if it
does if the odds were 50 and i had 10
dollars i'd break even playing this game
over time if babies mugged me every day
if the payoff is a hundred dollars then
i'd break even at ten percent odds if
the payoff is ten thousand dollars and
there's a better than a zero point one
percent chance which is 1 in 1 000 that
the baby delivers the 10 000 bucks to me
tomorrow and it only cost me 10 today
then it's actually a smart move in terms
of expected value one billion dollars
kevin
one
billion i will give you one billion
dollars tomorrow for stealing ten
dollars in your wallet today do the math
kevin
do the math
all right all right i'll do the math
alright so is there a 1 and 100 million
chance that this scenario is real that's
my break even point so if the odds are
say 1 in 50 million this is a great deal
theoretically if i'm wrong and it's one
in 125 million then i've made a really
bad decision here i mean
think about it what are the odds that a
super board billionaire is sitting
around with a few other really bored
billionaires and they're watching me as
they play some kind of creepy social
experiment
they could give the baby doll the money
tomorrow that sounds crazy and highly
unlikely but
is it possible
yeah
it's possible
at a certain point the odds that this
scenario is legit make giving up my
wallet worth it relative to the payoff
it's just a wallet and i lose 10 bucks
and i get a mathematically plausible
possibility of getting enough money to
change tens of thousands of lives maybe
more what would you do with 10 billion
dollars
or 100 billion dollars
i'd fill a swimming pool with peanut
butter and then
figure out the rest from there
the rewards here are very real and the
expected value calculations add up so
why would i not do this that's the
rational
decision it's like
a lottery that's mathematically
in my favor here's a question
can i even figure out the real odds in a
situation like this i'm not just
flipping a coin i'm wondering what a
weird inanimate doll
thing is going to do tomorrow a hardcore
mathematician fully committed to
expected value would happily take this
baby
mugger's deal but you're smarter than
that you know this isn't a good idea if
you give this baby your wallet you're
never seeing either one
ever again
a baby needs to steal 10 bucks today but
it's gonna pay you a billion tomorrow it
makes
no sense the baby knows the expected
value calculation too and understands
that it's perfectly rational for me to
give up my wallet so why wouldn't she
use that information to her advantage
and pose a scenario she can succeed with
100
of the time again
you're smarter than the math here
but can artificial intelligence realize
what you know
or
would it just play the numbers wait what
if it's not some weird lottery style
payoff what if the scenario is not a
good thing at all and instead is
something
terrifying
what if the baby says they've got a
biological weapon that will harm
millions and they'll unleash it unless
you give them your ten dollars
does giving up your wallet as a
preventative measure make more sense
than the scenario in which you're gonna
win a bunch of money should
the extremely low probability of
something really just converge
to being zero at what point do we just
consider such a small value meaningless
and
what if a very low probability event is
offered to a thousand people does it
make sense for us to press on it as
individuals but to accept it if we all
do it together in a group that's really
the impact of pascal's mugging based on
pascal's wager the centuries-old
philosophical argument about the
existence of god a scenario developed by
eliezer yudkowski and further explored
by nick bostrom has tested the limits of
belief in utilitarianism
expected value and decision making in
pretty weird scenarios if you want to
dive further into the origins of
pascal's mugging you can read their
explanations for free online and
you should but all of this
might matter to some not weird scenarios
like
recycling a single soda can probably
isn't gonna save the environment but we
have good reasons for thinking it'll
lead to an important payoff despite
being irrational on
the surface
at a certain point we really can't
comprehend how big something is or how
good it is or how dangerous it is so
how can we possibly program artificial
intelligence to make the decisions that
are actually in our best interest and
not just
based on the best raw calculation
so
is this deal actually a good deal for me
do i let the baby take my wallet for the
possibility of tremendous gain or to
avoid a horrible disaster even though i
know
it's
obviously absurd so you gonna give me
your wallet or not jack no
no
no i i'm not i
i personally would rather do a little
bit of good with my 10 bucks for sure
than risk it for a near impossible
monumental payoff but some of you
watching this video would likely have a
different answer and
that's okay we both have perfectly valid
conclusions and
one of the many crucial things to
consider as we advance artificial
intelligence is
understanding those critically important
nuances of
human intelligence
and
saddle shoe wearing grifter doll
intelligences
too i
guess
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
do the math kevin